Hey guys, how's it going? It's Justine. And today we are doing an unboxing of the new
Surface book 2 laptop. I know what you're saying, "Justine, aren't you the biggest Apple fan girl ever?" Yes, yes
I am. But this laptop is incredible
I absolutely love all of the service lines by Microsoft my main computer is my macbook with touch bar
It's the USB-C version that came out last year and my second computer is actually a surface studio
And I love this thing I love it so much. Most of my editing
I do everything all on Final Cut, but I started using Premiere a little bit more and know will not be
Replacing Final Cut. Don't worry. And those of you on the premiere Adobe side,
I just can't. I just, I just can't, I'm not ready.
Let's get into unboxing this what's new in the new surface book 2 is
They do look pretty much exactly like the previous version of the surface book, but there are now two models
This is the 15-inch model and there's also a 13-inch this
Also has a USB C port which I'm extremely excited about because most of my hard drives that I use they're all USB C
Thanks to the MacBook. This also has an SD card slot. I know what you're saying, "Wow!"
It'll also work with a surface dial
Which is I am a huge fan of it took a lot for this to fully integrate into other products
But this does now work with premiere which is kind of exciting cause you can scrub through the timeline. A lot of people I know
Edit with premiere and if they send me files
I need to at least be able to know how to change things around if need be. Let's start the unboxing
This is the 15 inch surface book it now comes in two different models
There's the 15 inch and the 13 inch you can
customize the smaller version with an i5 or an i7 and the 15 inch only comes with the i7
Processor. You can spec out the RAM up to 16 gigs you can also choose between various hard drives
This is the one terabyte 16 gig model
I wasn't even gonna do an unboxing this it was just gonna be a personal thing for me to open and look at and then I
Really did want to share it with you guys because a lot of you guys
Give me such a hard time for being such an apple fangirl and like yeah, I am a fangirl
But guess what I have been so impressed with a lot of the things that Microsoft has been doing especially with the Surface line like
This thing looks great, and it really does spec wise rival the Macbooks and also price wise
Why is because these are priced a little bit higher than I feel like normal laptops are because not only as a laptop
But it also can be a tablet you can detach the screen
And they have said that the tablet mode you can use for five hours
And with the screen attached in laptop mode you can run up to I quote 17 hours
But I'm pretty sure if I was editing videos or doing normal things that I would be doing on this laptop
It's not gonna last for 17 hours, but it's got some beefy beefy batteries in it
One of the things that is a little bit different in this model from the previous version
They made this hinge a little bit more sturdy so that it will be able to support the larger screen
So this is where you would be charging your laptop
They also added a new USBC port which I'm extremely excited about this could be used for data transfer and also
Charging and on the other side we have a SD card slot and two USB ports
This rain is huge definitely has some weight to it. It's probably heavier than my MacBook Pro. I would say if I had to guess
Let's turn it on while I turn that on let's see what else we've gotten here
Documentation, no thank you wow this is very heavy this has got to be our charging
Brick in here this thing is very heavy its
massive
This has a very very strong smell
Okay, it's just a moment. Yes. I'd like English please. Thank you. Hi. I'm Cortana hi there. I'm Cortana. No I'm Cortana
Are you Cortana. Sign in here, but touch a Wi-Fi there, and we'll have your PC ready for all you plan to do
Oh girl. Yeah. I'm a grown-up
If you need an assistive screen reader Stop. ...press the windows Shhh. control and enter keys at the same time to enable narrator
How do I Shh. Okay enough intro. Let's dig in. Well, what are you doing now?
Surface dial
I thought this was a little sticky tab. I didn't think that it popped the whole back of it all. Please holds.
I thought that peeled this little sticky back off. Let us know if this computer is owned by your work or scroll. Me.
It's yours. It's mine. Follow these instructions, and I'll meet you back here once it does. Yes
Thank you. Use Windows hello to unlock your PC. Quick as a wink with just your face
No wink required. Want to set that up now? Sure. Hold still for a second. Okay
We need to learn to recognize you. Learn me.
Cortana is super pleasant. Few more things polished up for you and Windows will be all yours. Looking forward to helping out! Me, too.
Let's set this up. So this is a little sticky tab that you pull off
Just like that and that's what I thought I was pulling off earlier
So right here is the little eject button when you press this it prepares your device before
Come here. Wow, tablet mode. This is really it's actually quite light. Do you want to switch a tablet mode?
Yes, and to attach it back on. We just do that same action
Voila do you want to exit tablet mode?
Yes, obviously switching to tablet mode will save your battery when you're using it in tablet mode
But I feel like I like having it. Ask me because maybe I'm not ready
Making sure. It's me does have the facial recognition which is kind of great
I use that pretty often on my surface studio
Which I talked about very very often especially with the new implementation of face ID on the new iPhone
I will say one of the things that I'm pretty excited about is the SD card slot
I know as crazy and simple as it is I'm excited about it because I go to a lot of shoots
And I shoot a lot of video and a lot of times
I like bringing the least amount of things as possible so before I'd have to rig my macbook separate hard drives dongles SD
Cards all of these things that try to make that work, so now I can just bring this in a hard drive
And I'm good to go
I also don't like bringing my main computer that I do all of my work on my editing and everything because I have so much
Information on that that I'm always so afraid that I'm gonna leave it somewhere
It's gonna get stolen now that I'm slowly learning Premiere - I'll still be able to do a little bit of editing on the go
With this but man, I really love Final Cut okay?
I love it so much at this point it would take me so much time to relearn everything
and to be as fast as I am and final cut and I was so slow and
Premier that that time wasted is very very valuable especially when it comes to editing and posting videos for you guys to another stylist
Does not come with a pen so I need my stylus separate. I guess so
All right
Hello, hello, mr.. Frizzell is pretty awesome. We just can attach that like south there it is
Am I'm doing all of the work that I did
You can choose between several different things especially in this app there aren't as many options
But depending upon which app you have open this dialog to various things so here we go we can zoom
zoom zoom zoom
Can adjust the volume
As you can see right there
All the little dial this thing's pretty awesome
Let me know if you guys would like me to make a follow-up video
Maybe like a day in the life with the surface book
I don't know. I've never really done one of those before but I thought maybe it could be really fun
Maybe to see how I would use this over my Mac and what I do with my Mac
Maybe just a day in the life of my gadgets what I don't know. I'm not sure well
See you guys in my next video
Thank you so much for watching leave me some comments below and let me know if there's anything else you would like to see me
Make in the future, and that's it. I'm gonna go editing now, so I'll see you later. Bye!